au soir les enfants
vous savez que demain vous allez tous
vous réveillez dans une nouvelle année
une bonne et heureuse année patron jean
suisse hulot c'est très important une
nouvelle année il faut faire des voeux
pour ses parents ses amis et il faut
prendre de bonnes résolutions qu'il ne
faut pas oublier mais qu'est ce que tu
as à gigoter un ciment chronos patron
j'étais déjà pris de bonnes résolutions
et hop je descends tu es bien pressé
nounours oui pas trop ce soir je veux à
l'ugtt ont su gros qu'aucun en voilà de
bonnes résolutions
hop hop hop voilà un beau paquet attend
avec un humour stage il va être encore
plus qu'en mai bonsoir les enfants mes
petits amis
une nouvelle chérie j'ai envie de te
procès
au peugeot avenue de la rue au lieu de
doubs on veut pas tu pourrais quand même
rien fait les beaux paquets qu'on a fait
mais lorsqu'on être papa pour notre à
mataro la fin lui la fa le sang bleu ou
rouge aux revenus ou pour ou y
alors malin tu sais nous nous regardent
plutôt mon beau paquet et oui c'est vrai
mais pas que où ils ont beaucoup de
succès pas que beaucoup elle est belle
car dit on voudrait écrire un défi ban
est même un je m'en vais vous écrire ça
les enfants pique plume tiens y'a des
oiseaux jadis maso je vous le dis on
c'est incroyable les oreillers
d'ornement les oreillers évident que
c'est pas mal ça mollo voyager car oui
il faut la houlala faisons ce fonds
[Musique]
photo un peu grâce à un simple de plus
qu'aux patrons a trop pataud et bien ils
finissent l'année en beauté nos petits
amis patrons demain si vous le voulez
plein nous ramènerons rémi toto et
fanfan chez laurent gbabo d'accord
nounours mais ce soir je vais essayer de
les calmer un peu je suis la marchande
stable la journée l min il faut être
raisonnable
[Musique]
c'est le moment d'aller au lit
maintenant je crois bien que nos petits
diables se sont calmés
allez vite vous couchez les petits et
demain vous pourrez dire à vos parents
bonne et heureuse année
bonne nuit à demain à double bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
où